human beings are emotionally driven
animals um we are not uh rational as
much as people like to think we are
we're not even if you're an engineer
you're we're still emotional um you know
we make decisions out of fear and ego
and ambition and insecurity and all
these things um uh and the part of the
brain that controls our emotions is
called the lyic brain but that part of
the brain doesn't control language um it
also controls all human behavior by the
way so it controls our emotions and
behavior but it doesn't control language
which is why it's difficult
to put our emotions into words we often
use analogies and metaphors it's like
this it's like I'm on a train and
there's no end to the track you know um
um it's also uh why we sometimes
struggle to explain our decisions I
don't know it just felt right right I
just trusted my gut oh I should have
trusted my gut right well there's no
part of your stomach that makes
decisions it's it's this lyic brain the
neocortex is our rational part of our
brain that's responsible for rational
analytical thinking and language but
it's not responsible for behavior and so
when you make a rational case for why it
actually doesn't work because it's
rational uh when you to make an
emotional case for why that's when you
create human connection and the easier
way to understand that is that the why
has nothing to do with the job the job
is the rational part the job is the
Tactical part the job um is the thing
that we can look at and count metrics
but that's not the essence of of human
connection right um so by saying family
first you know and then Mission because
mission is the job the flying is the job
the war fighting is the job but it's
something higher it's the deep bond that
is what creates um where the why exists
you're 100% right and it can be
ideological and it can be family it can
be human it can be anything but it has
to live on a level higher than the job
and I see this mistake done a lot of
times by a lot of leaders which is they
attempt to explain the why with a
rational explanation or just a
rearticulation of the job so our why is
to build the best quality product at the
highest quality value like no that's not
it you know our why is to fly planes
better than nope that's not it right um
the why is take per take care of the
person to the left of you and to the
right of you and if we do that we'll fly
planes better than anybody else I mean
that kind of thing um and people who
resonate with that cause will find
themselves drawn to that organization